the coronavirus situation continues to
degrade abroad as america prepares at
home and Nancy Pelosi blows up a
bipartisan stimulus bill I'm Ben Shapiro
this is the Ben Shapiro show today's
show is sponsored by expressvpn my savvy
fans secure their Internet join them and
expressvpn comm slash my mother when I
say like hackers are really active
there's like several family members
history they got hacked so like get your
VPN now Express VPN comm slash Ben okay
so I hope you had a wonderful and non
relaxing weekend I hope you had a
relaxing weekend but let's be frank
about it none of this is relaxing all of
this is guaranteed to lead to anxiety
even I your Placid host I normally have
fairly low blood pressure well my wife
took my blood pressure recently let's
just say it was way above normal and
that is I think fairly normal for
everybody at this point we're all in
this together right me I've got my
Churchill poster up behind me we're in
it together poster okay the reality is
that this is a crisis of proportions
that we have not seen in my lifetime I
think in virtually anybody's lifetime
certainly since World War Two and the
extent of the crisis is not yet known
and that's what makes this so difficult
is that when it comes to trying to
figure out exactly where the data lead
us we are short on data at this point
and so on the one hand I'm hearing calls
from some people saying you're taking
this whole thing too seriously not that
many people have died yet and on the
other hand I'm hearing people say you're
taking this you're taking this way too
seriously you know you're just you're
not taking this seriously enough you're
suggesting that we should keep an eye on
the economy and really at this point we
should just be protecting life here's
the deal here's where I am right at this
moment I think I am where a lot of
people are right at this moment I am
perfectly willing to put everything on
hold until we know what exactly the
projections that look like because we
have not yet seen the curve been down in
any western country other than South
Korea South Korea would be the only
outlier we have a couple of Asian
countries Singapore Hong Kong that
presumably the curve has been town we
cannot trust the statistics from
probably either Hong Kong or China
considering they're directed by the
Chinese Communist Party which lied about
this thing in the first place but
because we have not seen enough
statistics yet nobody knows exactly
where we stands right now what we are
gambling is potential future economic
loss from which we could recover against
a certainty of loss of life and we don't
know exactly how much loss of life
there's going to
my prediction is that by the end of this
week especially looking at the European
countries not even looking at the United
States looking at Italy looking at Spain
that by the end of this week we're gonna
have a much better idea of where exactly
things stand and that's true in both
terms of the economy and the and the
guarantee damage to the economy that
happens when you shut down the entire
world economy forcibly the way we have
done at the government level and in
terms of loss of life because what we've
seen in Italy is mild optimism at this
hour because well tons of people are
dying particularly in northern Italy
from coronavirus some 650 700 a day it
seems like that may be evening off and
leveling out now one of the things that
you should be aware of when you look at
the charts is that the chart that really
matters is the day on day growth not
accumulative stats the cumulative stats
don't matter very much because again if
you're gonna look at cumulative stats
they're always gonna continue to grow
because none of the cases ever really
come off the board or very few fav Airy
few cases tend to come off the board
because there's like a two to three week
lag time before somebody actually comes
off the board what you really want to
see is whether the number of new
diagnosed cases and nut and new deaths
is leveling off day by day hopefully the
rate of growth levels to zero and at
that point then you can declare that the
pandemic is basically over although
again you may get a second wave pandemic
so we don't have that much information
yet we just don't know and because we
don't know in the absence of information
governments are acting because what
other choice do they have if this thing
goes worst case scenario and then two
million people die and if this thing is
cases best case scenario presumably
we'll know that over the next couple of
weeks it's why President Trump was
getting all sorts of flack this morning
because he was watching Steve Hilton's
show on Fox pretty obviously and see
Fulton is good dude he did a man a
monologue about the the potential of an
economic catastrophe and how many lives
that cost what kind of damage that was
going to do and he got all sorts of
flack for this because we live in this
weird internet world where you are not
supposed to even think about at this
point the trade-offs of government
policy now there's no question there are
trade-offs the government policy
millions of Americans are going to lose
their jobs right now and that is in fact
a trade off now we can say that that
trade-off is certainly worth it when we
don't know the extent of the possible
loss of human life we can say that right
now but to save the people they are not
even allowed to consider the trade-offs
of government policy that as we gather
information we're not allowed to better
calibrate government policy because if
we save one
life then we then that is worth
everything that obviously is not true I
mean that obviously is not true
throughout American policy forever and
always we were going to calculate the
extent of public policy losses on the
one side force of public policy gains on
the other side right now the big problem
is I keep saying over and over is lack
of data and so I'm not gonna be sucked
into the game where I say I know that
things are gonna level off I don't know
things are gonna level off and I'm also
not gonna be sucked into the game where
I say I know the things are gonna go
exponential growth because I don't know
they're gonna go exponential growth and
neither to you and neither do any of the
experts if the experts really knew all
this stuff they would be presenting that
data to the public and if the experts on
these so-called other side knew that
this thing we're gonna level off then
they would be presenting all of their
findings and then we could decide but
the fact is at this point all we really
have is an enormous amount of
speculation and so in the absence of
hard data I'm gonna say hold on just
hold on right what we're doing right now
seems like a smart policy in terms of
the lockdowns that can't last forever as
I said last Friday I don't see a plan to
end this in any near-term fashion I
don't see any any sort of projections
from the government as to what they hope
to achieve over the next two or three
weeks or the next two months for that
matter that is gonna lock this thing
down increase our medical capacity
prevent us from from moving over that
line of medical capacity I don't see
what the government is like what are
their projections at this point we just
don't have enough information the
government's not presenting us
information so I'm gonna give you the
president from said yesterday after
watching Steve Hilton he tweeted out we
cannot let the cure be worse than the
problem itself and he said that at the
end of the 15 days shutdown period we'll
make a decision as to which way we want
to go and he got all sorts of flack for
this how dare he say this sort of thing
is he just watching Fox News and making
policy based on Fox News first of all I
really don't think that that is
unreasonable I think on a day to day
level the federal government should be
considering exactly what policies we are
putting in place state government should
be doing that too he's not saying at the
end of 15 days he's gonna go everybody
out there enjoy your life he's just
saying at the end of 15 days as we
gather more data we're going to have to
figure out whether our policy is best
calibrated to our doing what it seeks to
do which is save lives and yes also to
save the economy because again we could
have upward a 30% unemployment that's
gonna have some pretty significant life
ramifications for literally hundreds of
millions of people in the United States
alone and billions of people around the
globe so all of this is extraordinarily
complicated there are no easy answers
and to pretend that reevaluating in 50
days like the end of the world I don't
understand are we supposed to not revile
you ate in 15 days what would be stupid
is to evaluate wrongly in 15 days then
let everybody out
off lockdown if in fact we're still
undergoing exponential growth in death
and infection rates in the United States
that would be idiotic policy but Trump
isn't saying that's exactly what he's
gonna do he's just saying we have to
reevaluate we should be re-evaluating on
an ongoing basis and we also do have to
weigh all of the various complications
here because what you're gonna hear from
the health community is exactly right
that in their best of all possible
worlds we lock down for like nine months
until there's a vaccine or 12 or 18
months until there's a vaccine but
health policy wonks are also not
economic long and economic long sir not
health policy wonks and there are very
few people who bridge the gap between
health policy wonk
and economic wonk if you're a doctor
right now they're telling you stay home
and if you're an economist they're
saying go to work right because the fact
is that these two priorities are
directly opposed to one another so the
question becomes when does the balance
tip away from we're all gonna die in the
pandemic or a huge number of people
particularly elderly are gonna die in
the pandemic and toward a bunch of
people are gonna have their lives ruined
by the economic shutdown when does that
when does this balance tip and we don't
know the answer to that I keep saying we
don't know it's okay to say we don't
know it really is okay if you hear
people out there expressing with
certainty that they know it's because
they're lying to you nobody knows yet
nobody no okay we're gonna get some more
of this in just a second we're gonna get
to the two sides of the coin that are
being presented one thing is certain
this week is gonna get a lot worse in
terms of the number of infections and
deaths in the United States because that
has happened in Spain it has happened in
Italy also we're doing inordinate
amounts of testing like huge amounts of
testing finally late we're finally doing
that in the United States we're gonna
see prominent people get this thing I
assume there will be prominent people
who probably die of this thing over the
next two or three weeks because again it
is infecting presumably hundreds of
thousands of people in the United States
we'll get to all of that in just one
second first as I mentioned very early
on this is like a hackers paradise
everybody on planet earth everyone on
planet Earth is on the internet right
now and that means that because you're
on the internet right now hackers are
just looking for a way to grab your
credit card information I mean the fact
is that if you're online like 24 hours
it is the rest of us are checking the
news or watching TV trying keep your
kids entertained if you're doing all
those things in your online all the time
what better time would there be for
online criminals to go grab at your
information and this
is why you need a VPN you need it right
now I said before you need a VPN if
you're online a lot well now everybody
is online a lot expressvpn can protect
you expressvpn crates a secure encrypted
tunnel between your device and the
Internet so your online activity can't
be seen by anyone expressvpn works on
everything phones laptops routers
everyone who shares your Wi-Fi can still
be protected even if they do not have
expressed VPN the best part is using
Express VPN is as easy as closing the
bathroom door it's very simple you put
it on your computer you click one button
you're good to go
if you're like me and you believe your
online activity is your business secure
yourself by visiting expressive VPN comm
slash been today use my exclusive link
expr ESS VPN comm / pen you get an extra
three months for free that's expressive
VPN calm / Ben go check them out right
now and protect yourself on the
interwebs okay so as I have said this
week is going to be bad it's gonna be
bad in terms of the stats it's gonna be
bad in terms of the deaths we know that
because finally we're testing and
finally people are starting to go into
the hospital who have this thing so this
is the week when the rubber hits the
road and the pedal hits the metal as
they say Surgeon General dr. Jerome
Adams warned on Monday the corona virus
outbreak will worsen this week he said
people across the country are not taking
the threat seriously enough now he's
saying what he's supposed to say because
the fact is that if you're not locked in
your house and staying away from other
people then according to the doctors
you're basically doing it wrong and that
is right I mean that is why you're
seeing cities across the United States
like here in LA yesterday my family we
wanted to get out of the house so we
drove by Griffith Park it was packed we
drove away and we got we didn't even get
out of the car we just kept driving
because everybody wants to get out right
now because the sunshine does make you
feel better I have advised people you
need to take a walk a day it's all true
also stay away from the other humans so
Adams said I want Americans to
understand this is gonna get bad he said
the disease is spreading because many
people especially young people are not
abiding by guidance to stay home and
practice social distancing we are seeing
young people who are coming down with
this it is not nearly the rates of
elderly people or people with
pre-existing conditions there's a 12
year old girl in Georgia who came down
with this is in critical condition
there was an 18 year old I believe in
Italy who just died so there are young
people who are coming down with this and
even young people coming down with this
you can sustain fairly significant lung
damage according to some of the studies
Adam says right now there not enough
people out there who are taking this
seriously
Adam said the young people were flocking
to the beaches in California people were
still headed to the National
in Washington to view the cherry blossom
trees that bloom each year he warned
that young people need to understand
they can contract covin 19 and they can
be hospitalized and potentially die from
it now it is also true that your chances
of that happening not contracting up a
dime from it are extremely low if you
are young not lower than if you contract
the flu if you're young but lower than
old people or people who have some sort
of pre-existing condition but Adam says
everyone needs to act as if they have
the virus right now so test or no test
we need you to understand you could be
spreading it to someone else or you
could be getting it from someone else
stay at home and he was also answering
questions about the supply chains he
said the supply chains are indeed
opening ok so on the one hand you have
everybody every expert saying that you
need to stay home right now to flatten
the curve on the other hand Michael 11
Nobel laureate Stanford biophysicists
began analyzing the number of Kobe 19
cases worldwide in January correctly
calculated that China would get through
the worst of its coronavirus outbreak
long before many health experts had
predicted according to Yahoo News now he
first sees a similar outcome in the
United States and the rest of the world
he says what we need to do is control
the panic we're gonna be fine he says
absolutely people need to stay home but
he says the rate of increase and the
number of deaths will slow even more
over the next week now again the rate of
increase does not mean the number of
deaths is going to slow it means the
rate of increase in the number of deaths
so what that means is Italy had 750
deaths or so on Sunday they had 650 or
Saturday that's 650 deaths or so on
Sunday all that is terrible all that is
awful every one of those deaths a
tragedy but 650 is less than 750 he's
saying ok and if tomorrow you have 5 54
53 52 50 and pretty soon this thing
levels off we're having very few deaths
and that's what you've seen in China so
with his hope is that we're going to see
this thing starting to level off right
now we have three hundred and fifty four
thousand total confirmed cases of
coronavirus all across the globe with
about 15,000 deaths thus far Italy has
seen a huge number because again their
health system got overwhelmed that's
what we are trying to prevent here Italy
has seen 59,000 138 cases as of this
hour with almost 5500 total deaths
they're experiencing hundreds of deaths
a day and that is because their system
is completely overwhelmed you're seeing
the United States we have 35,000 300
confirmed cases that is going up fairly
significantly 473 deaths now what you're
seeing in some of these countries is a
wild difference
in the death-rate right if I read you
those stats again what you'll see is
that in Italy you're seeing almost a 10%
death rate basically you're seeing a 9%
death rate from people who are confirmed
to people who have died in the United
States the death rate is still like 1.2
1.3 percent and as we test more and more
it seems like those rates are going down
not up in Spain again the health system
has been overwhelmed and you're starting
to see the rates rise if 33,000
confirmed cases 2,200 deaths there the
things are getting bad over there but
Germany has 27,000 confirmed cases and
only 115 deaths and that is because
supposedly they've really locked
everything down pretty tight and glamour
chol locked everything down Angela
Merkel in fact just went into self
quarantine herself Germany has now been
groups of more than two to stop
coronavirus Angela Merkel has self
quarantined after she came into contact
her doctor had tested positive for
coronavirus and she said she'd isolate
herself at home effective immediately we
are seeing prominent people or coming
down with this thing we've seen the the
husband of Amy Klobuchar apparently came
down with this he was apparently
coughing up blood and and he is now on
oxygen he's not on a ventilator yet
hopefully that remains the case Senator
Rand Paul came down with this thing as
well over the weekend that of course was
very big news he tested positive for the
corona virus his office announced in a
statement on Sunday he's the first
senator third member of Congress to test
positive one member of Congress from
Utah has already been hospitalized for
this thing Paul was asymptomatic tested
out of an abundance of caution due to
his extensive travel and events
according to his office he has self
quarantine since but he went to the gym
so that's that's wonderful he went to
the gym like the day that he was that he
was found to have coronavirus so that
brought him some pretty significant
criticism from his fellows as frankly it
should I mean nobody should be going to
the gym right now I criticize Bill
DeBlasio for last week so Rand Paul is
not exempt from that Mike Lee and Mitt
Romney said they would be self
quarantine and they cited Paul's
diagnosis and the advice of the
attending physician of the US Congress
from President Trump was bad at about a
little bit yesterday because President
Trump seemed to make a reference to Mitt
Romney who's asked about Romney as self
quarantine and here's what President
Trump had to say about it on top of
Senator Paul now four senators are in
isolation
and the rules say that in order to vote
there one of the two about wrong there's
the senator and senator Rick Scott also
two of them word contact with Rick is
coming out with the critical stimulus
package vote expect Romney's imagination
yes yeah gee that's too bad sarcasm
there okay so everybody in the in the
room is like wait are you making fun of
Mitt Romney for being an isolation now
he has the plausible deniability does
Trump of being able to say no he was
just being perfectly genuine except that
he singled out Romney there okay you can
read that one however you want is that
just Trump being remarkably callous
about a coronavirus self-isolation
or is that Trump actually expressing
sympathy read that however you like I
have a feeling that people who love
Trump are gonna say no he was being
perfectly generous of spirit in in
referencing Romney there and people
don't like Trump again be like yeah that
when he says gee that doesn't sound
exactly like somebody who is who's
experiencing tremendous amounts of
sympathy for somebody who is now twelve
self-quarantine II put that aside to
other members of Congress representative
Mario diaz-balart Republican of Florida
and represented ben mcadams have also
tested positive for the virus over a
dozen others have since self isolated
after coming into contact with them or
other individuals who had tested
positive for kovat 19 so as this thing
continues to develop obviously you're
gonna see more and more prominent people
get it some of the prominent people who
are getting it are have been recovering
Daniel take him from the series lost
which was one of my favorite series when
it was on TV
he played he played gin I believe was
the name of his character and aunt
annual day Kim came down with
coronavirus he said he had a bit of a
rough time but the new drug cocktail
that is now you know being tested all
over the world this hydroxychloroquine
as well as his in throw myosin he said
that that really helped help him recover
here's what he had to say about it
here's what I consider to be the secret
weapon
hydroxychloroquine this is a common
anti-malarial drug that has been used
with great success in korea in their
fight against the corona virus and yes
this is the drug that the president
mentioned the other day it is also the
drug that dr. Anthony Falchi cautioned
us about he said that evidence that the
drug was promising is anecdotal and that
is correct it means it was a study and
it's only based on personal accounts
well add my name to those personal
accounts because I am feeling better
okay so that is true that foul she did
caution people because President Trump
had gone out and a presser and had
talked about this this drug cocktail and
then foul she went out and he sort of
hesitated he said listen President Trump
is trying to bring hope to people and
well gets a doctor foul in just a second
in his relationship with Trump because
obviously foul Qi is is using whatever
capacity he has to try and convince
Trump to say things he wants him to say
and he's not having complete success at
that we'll get to that in a little bit
but here was foul Qi hesitating on the
drug cocktail last week saying you know
we don't want to over blow this thing
before we have clinical trials in on it
the president has heard as we all have
heard what are what I call anecdotal
reports that certain drugs work so what
he was trying to do an express was the
hope that if they might work let's try
and push their usage I on the other side
have said I'm not disagreeing with the
fact anecdotally they might work but my
job is to prove definitively from a
scientific standpoint that they do work
so I was taking a purely medical
scientific standpoint and the president
was trying to bring hope to the people
okay and and there's there's truth to
that it is also true by the way they
it's not like an go to your doctor and
ask for a prescription on this thing and
doctors gonna have to recommend it they
have put out notices to virtually every
hospital in the United States that if
you recommend this without there being a
proper reason to recommend it that
you're depleting the supply okay we're
gonna get to more of all of this in one
second plus the giant legislative battle
that is broken out over the coronavirus
federal financial response because we
are now in uncharted financial territory
we'll get to the kind of policy we
should be pursuing versus the kind of
policy that some members the government
seems to want us to pursue okay first if
you seem to be losing sleep lately I
know me too well
one thing that can help you at least
when you are sleeping be comfortable you
know is your helix sleep mattress let me
just tell you I appreciate it
I have a new baby it means I'm not
getting tons of sleep and I'm pretty
stressed out which means I'm not getting
tons of sleep I mean I got parents in
their 60s so I'm a little bit worried
about everything going on but when I lie
down on the mattress I want to be able
to close my eyes and relax good news for
me there's a mattress made just for me
this is helix sleep helix sleep has a
quiz it takes just two minutes to
complete
matches your body type and sleep
preferences to the perfect mattress for
you whether you're a side sleeper or a
hot sleeper whether you like a plush or
from bed with helix there's no more
confusion and no more compromising helix
sleep is rated the number one mattress
by GQ and Wired magazine CNN called it
the most comfortable mattress they've
ever slept on and this times Hannon was
telling the truth just go to helix sleep
calm /ban take their two minutes sleep
because my wife and I have it really is
comfortable they'll match you to a
customized mattress that will give you
the best sleep of your life they got a
10 year warranty you can try it out for
a hundred nights risk-free so what
exactly are you waiting for
helix is offering up to 200 bucks off
all mattress orders for our listeners
they're gonna spend like half your life
on this thing so really get a mattress
that is fantastic for you and helix
Klebe it can make you do it it's a 200
saw fit helix sleep comm slash pen that
is helix sleep comm slash man go check
them out right now helix sleep comm
slash bent so as I keep saying
everything right now is geared toward
not becoming Italy the horror stories
from Italy are really frightening
obviously and again raise questions as
to on the one hand we got it not be
Italy on the other hand what if there's
a second wave even after we tamp this
thing down and let people out again so
on the first hand you know when we talk
about tamping this thing down to the
point where were not Italy there's an
Israeli medical doctor named guy Peleg
he just told Israeli television that
northern Italy the orders are not to
allow anybody over 60 access to
respiratory machines so you come in and
you're over 60 in northern Italy and you
can't breathe and they're basically well
you're on your own which is just insane
because they're trying to save younger
people who have a better shot at life
the rationing care by the way Italy does
have a single-payer system so anybody
who suggests to you that a single-payer
health care system is a is a cure-all to
the problems that ill the American
health care system yeah not not so much
not so much meanwhile in Asia on the
other hand there are second waves that
are apparently breaking out in various
different countries when Australia's
Bondi Beach according to Yahoo News to
the streets of New Delhi authorities
across Asia have ramped up efforts to
stem the spread of cool
a virus amid fears of a second wave of
infection in places where outbreaks had
appeared under control outside China
South Korea is the hardest-hit country
in Asia with more than 8,500 cases while
the number of infections in China is
supposedly falling other countries are
seeing the toll gather pace from spread
of the highly contagious virus cases
rose by roughly a third in Thailand
overnight to nearly 600 fueling
skepticism about claims in Myanmar and
Laos of zero infections one of the big
problems here is the democratic
countries tend to be honest and
transparent about the number of
infections and deaths they've seen which
is what you're singing Italy according
to Rush everything's hunky-dory but
that's because Russia is a dictatorship
that is why we can't trust China either
China's like yeah we're fine we've seen
sporadic reports out of China that are
not even doing testing anymore
specifically so that they can keep the
numbers down of the number of infected
and the number of dead meanwhile there
are serious concerns that there will be
a second wave the minute you let people
out Singapore is banning all short-term
visitors to the densely populated city
state after a surge of imported cases
took its total to 445 including its
first two deaths on Saturday in Hong
Kong the number of cases nearly doubled
in the past week as more and more people
were flying back to the financial hub
which does raise the question as I
raised on Friday okay well how long can
you keep everybody locked down how long
can you keep everybody locked down
because if you let everybody back out in
three weeks and you have not radically
increased the medical capacity available
and then there's a second wave and it
overwhelms the system what exactly have
you prevented and you're not gonna reach
anything remotely approaching hurt
immunity until sixty percent of the
population has had coronavirus and moved
on so where we go from here is of course
the big question meanwhile the federal
response continues to be I would say at
least at the very at the very least
chaotic some of the things are happening
some very chaotic things are happening
as well in good news the FDA is finally
relaxing restrictions on ventilators
which again isn't it demonstrative of
how giant bureaucracies are not
wonderful when the FDA finally like on
Sunday is now releasing restrictions on
ventilators we don't have to go through
the FDA process to get these things
approved to mean people are literally
gonna die in hospitals if they don't get
the ventilators and it took until Sunday
for the FDA to be like oh yeah maybe
we'll waive some of these ridiculous
requirements on how the ventilators are
supposed to work the FDA said on Sunday
hospitals and healthcare professionals
may now repurpose ventilators that were
rigidly intended for other environments
I'm glad they finally got on
the game for example the agency said
hospitals could adapt ventilators that
are now used in ambulances for use on
patients who are being treated inside at
their facilities in addition the agency
said that manufacturers that would
normally need FDA clearance to modify
events later could now do it without an
agency review the FDA said this would
help companies speed up their
manufacturing by attaining ventilator
parts from automobile manufacturers or
other companies that don't currently
make medical devices which of course the
this should been relieved weeks ago
obviously and when people talk about the
wonders of the federal government just
recognize that the wonders of the
federal government put these
restrictions in place in the first place
which is obviously not good news so what
exactly can the government do at this
point to to stop all of this long
article over at the New York Times
discussing what exactly the measures are
that could help alleviate this situation
the answer is a lot of lockdowns
I mean basically avoid contact there
there's some aspects here that have not
really been tested like you know when we
shut down all the schools it was not
great social science that led to the
shutdown in the schools and in the New
York Times reporting as much that's not
right winger ben shapiro that's the
left-wing New York Times suggesting that
maybe these giant school lockdowns and
sending kids home has actually increased
the chances of kids giving the
infections of their grandparents because
while they may not get sick they become
carriers to the grandparents but
basically everything has to be locked
down for the moment the problem is that
has extraordinary consequences for the
economy so we're gonna get to the
economy in just one second because this
is the this is the countervailing is it
this is sort of the countervailing
interest here the longer this goes on
the more we're gonna have to determine
what exactly is the balance between that
which we hoped first saw on the public
health level and that which we hope to
first all on the financial level we'll
get to that in just one second first
with the current economic climate you
must be on top of the numbers for your
business if you're not on top of the
numbers for your business you may be
putting your entire business at risk I
mean right now businesses are existing
on a Razors Edge you need to be on top
of your data we at the Daly where we
spend an inordinate amount of time being
on top of our data you should too and
you have to have the right tools to do
that if you want to take your company
from 2 to mil at 2 million to 10 million
or 10 million to hundreds of millions in
revenue or if you just want to prevent
massive losses to your company you need
NetSuite by Oracle when that's what you
get a full picture of your business
finance inventory HR customers and more
it's everything you need to grow and
everything
run as efficiently as humanly possible
all in one place run your entire
business from anywhere even if you're
working from home with NetSuite
you are covered responsible business
owners know their numbers like down to
the nitty gritty we here at Ailey where
do you need to as well schedule your
free product tour right now receive your
free guide six ways to run a more
profitable business and NetSuite comm
/ban that is n ET sui te dot-com slash
man NetSuite dot-com slash man go check
them out right now they're the number
one cloud business system trusted by
more than twenty thousand companies you
should be one it's the last business
system you're gonna need NetSuite
business grows here NetSuite comm slash
been alright so as I say the big
question when it comes to the economic
response is how many deaths are we for
stalling by shutting down the entire
economy and how many deaths are we
causing and how many jobs are we causing
to be lost by shutting down the entire
economy and to pretend that we can't do
these actuarial investigations at all is
idiotic obviously we have to be doing
those sorts of considerations right we
make those sorts of considerations every
single day right those sorts of
considerations are the basis of
government policy now that doesn't mean
that we come down on the side of open
everything up go out and enjoy your life
again we don't have enough data yet to
suggest this thing isn't gonna go
completely exponential and wipe out two
million people from the United States
population but as these statistics begin
to accrue they're gonna be some
interesting arguments over when exactly
people should be able to get back to
work and go out again and get this
economy moving again right now as we say
the members of the government are
talking about how bad this is gonna be
we'll find out Andrew Cuomo of New York
you said yesterday that 80% of people
are gonna get the virus and it could
last nine months which does again raise
that question
okay so what's gonna change in the next
three that allows us to get back to work
so if you think that people are gonna
stay home for nine months nine months
you're crazy I mean we've been doing
this for like nine days and people are
saving you wonder why the parks are full
you don't want to know why the beaches
are full because human beings are social
creatures now doesn't mean this is what
you should be doing but realistically
speaking the harsher the government
responds in terms of stay home the less
long this can last
so when Governor Cuomo says 80% of
people are gonna get the virus people
can be like okay well if you're not
upping your game in terms of preventing
death and 80% of people are gonna get it
then are we better off getting it now
are we better getting it better off
getting it later Italy says we're better
off getting it later because we're gonna
get completely overwhelmed the question
is
what can we do to prevent the overwhelm
now so that when 80 percents of people
get it a huge number of people don't die
here is andrew cuomo yesterday governor
of New York saying 80% of people are
going to get the virus it could last
nine months the context on the numbers
is important we're talking 10,000 etc
you look at any World Health
Organization or the NIH or whatever any
of the other countries are saying you
have to expect that at the end of the
day 40% to 80% of the population is
going to be infected so the only
question is how fast is the rate to that
40% 80% and can you slow that rate so
your hospital system can deal with it
okay then and what he's saying there is
absolutely correct right how how much do
we have to slow the rate so the hospital
system can deal with it and we've heard
no estimates so far from anybody on how
fast we can get the hospital system
ramped up to deal with all of this
Cuomo also went out in slam city
residents for going out which again in
the midst of a pandemic you really
should be listening to the government at
this time and you should stay home like
going out isn't your responsible thing
to do here is Andrew Cuomo there is a
density level in New York City that is
wholly inappropriate you would think
there was nothing going on in parts of
New York City you would think it was
just a bright sunny Saturday this is
just a mistake it's a mistake it's
insensitive it's arrogant
it's self-destructive it's disrespectful
to other people and it has to stop and
it has to stop now okay well again I'm
not gonna disagree with any of this
right right now we got to give it our
best shot right now we've got to give it
our best shot to lock this thing down
but we better start getting some data
pretty soon because it does appear that
right now the this thing is gonna go
political very quickly and this is what
a lot of people are afraid of what a lot
of people are afraid of is that this
thing gets political very quickly that
the worse the government responses to
this the more we are locked down the
faster politicians start to politicize
and that is happening in real time I
mean we're
it happened in real time and that's very
scary too because again when we're
talking about various competing
interests you've got the economy which
is a massive competing interest you've
got the the health of the United States
which of course is the greatest interest
and then you have the policies of the
United States that could in fact change
radically over the next year such that
the very nature of the United States
itself is changed and they're
politicians who are trying to take
advantage of this stuff there really are
okay the the ROM manual once had never
let a good crisis go to waste
yeah well this is the greatest crisis in
the history of the United States except
for possibly the Civil War I mean it is
a greater crisis than World War two
because the u.s. population was actually
less threatened in World War two than it
is right now by this pandemic and the
government response has been
significantly broader even than World
War two which is incredible or I mean
you've got literally hundreds and half
the population of the United States
locked down state after state now
declaring lock downs this has some
pretty significant ramifications for our
freedom so what I'm saying is everybody
better tread pretty lightly and be ready
to reevaluate on a moment's notice as
more data comes in and the greater the
crisis the more government intervention
is necessary and then there are people
who want to make that government
intervention ISM permanent as a matter
of politics and have wanted to for a
very long time so as we watch sector
after sector that hits the chopping
block the question becomes okay what
should our response be on all of this I
mean billionaire real estate investor
Tom Barak said that the US commercial
mortgage market is now on the brink of
collapse he predicted a domino effect of
catastrophic economic consequences if
banks and governments don't take prompt
action to keep borrowers from defaulting
because he's saying that there could be
a chain reaction of margin calls mass
foreclosures evictions and potentially
bank failures due to the corona virus
pandemic he says to keep people employed
you have to support the employers the
biggest part of the employer expenses
rent when commerce stops and they can't
pay rent and they can't pay interest on
the debt and the banks and
intermediaries cannot pay their
investors and then it all collapses
right so this thing it better get shored
up in short order and yet and yet the
politics playing did not stop yesterday
on a variety of scores so you saw for
example Andrew Cuomo who again I think
is not doing a bad job in terms of
letting his population know you gotta
lock this thing down at the same time
Cuomo turned to the Trump administration
said I want you to nationalize the
entire factory system basically I want
you to nationalize the entire chain of
medical device production which is
completely unnecessary okay really is
his suggestion is you're gonna get
dates bidding against each other to get
these masks and get these medical
devices okay question why do you think
that the federal government is going to
be better at producing things than the
private industry is if you written just
the way the market works if states are
competing to pay top dollar for this
stuff don't you think that every
business owner mainly business owners
foreign industries that are completely
defunct right now it's they've been shut
down are gonna shift their production
over as fast as humanly possible to
making the ventilators making the mask
this is happening in real time
nonetheless andrew Cuomo says let's
nationalize the factories and you get
the feeling this is somebody who's been
interested in nationalizing resources
for quite a while
I think the federal government should
order factories to manufacture masks
gowns ventilators the essential medical
equipment that's going to make the
difference between life and death
it's not hard to make a mask or PPE
equipment or a gown but you need
companies to do it
we have apparel companies that can make
clothing well then you can make a
surgical gown and you can make a mask
but they have to be ordered to do it
okay again that is unnecessary you know
who says that send necessary dr. Anthony
found you who everybody sort of trust on
this duffy says we don't need to
nationalize anything everybody's ramping
up who do you think has been providing
the tests its quest who do you think has
been providing all of these supply
chains that have allowed you to continue
going to the supermarket that's a
private industry here's factory saying
no we don't need nationalization but the
president was saying is that these
companies are coming forth on their own
and I think that's an extraordinary
spirit of the American spirit of not
needing to be coaxed they're stepping
forward they're making not only masks
but PPEs and now ventilators so what
we're gonna be seeing and and we're
seeing it already in the beginning
obviously there was an issue with
testing the testing now a large number
of testicle about now out there because
the private companies have gotten
involved it's time to present true and
again private companies are better at
this than the federal bureaucracy they
just are by the way this is what
happened during World War two also the
the the government did not nationalize
all the industries they went to private
industry they said we need your help and
we are going to make orders from you and
Ford suddenly turned into a plane
manufacturing company I mean this
the way private industry in the United
States responds this is widely sleek the
sleeping giant of American industry has
been awakened and it is responding as
opposed to FEMA I mean you should heard
the FEMA chief yesterday he was asked
direct questions on medical supply to
distribution he was like I don't know
because the government never knows okay
here's the FEMA chief who didn't know
the answers on basic medical supply
distribution at this point do you have
any specific numbers on how many masks
the federal government has been able to
acquire and how many have gone out the
door to hospitals it is it is a dynamic
and fluid operation do you have even a
rough number I can't give you a rough
number I can tell you that it's
happening every day and my mission is
operational coordination of all of these
things and that's my focus okay again
the government is just not as good at
any of this stuff as private industry is
the only thing that you need from the
government is the resources to pay for
all of this stuff to make sure that
everybody gets what they need but well
you need private industry to do is what
private industry does best which is
produce things at low cost and fast
right that that is what capitalism does
it meanwhile as you say I said everybody
is playing politics what this stuff is
not just about nationalization obviously
the big story of the day is the
Democrats killing this massive two
trillion dollar stimulus package from
the Republican Congress Sisson was
already pre negotiated and let's be real
about this I mean we are at the brink we
are at the financial brink at this point
where so much of the financial bring
that the Federal Reserve has basically
become the central policy maker in the
United States the Federal Reserve
announced today asset purchases with no
limit to support the markets so the
Federal Reserve which once was designed
to simply prevent runs on banks is now
the single greatest investor in American
industry they're gonna be buying up
corporate bonds like all the basically
the only thing they won't buy is basic
stock they're not gonna buy into the
stock market the wreck of my equities
but they are gonna be buying up
corporate bonds just to make sure that
these businesses don't go under why
because Congress can't to act and I
can't get their stupid act together
because they're terrible at this because
some people are busy grandstanding over
over all of this the Federal Reserve
said on Monday it's gonna launch a
barrage of programs aimed at helping
markets function more efficiently amid
the coronavirus crisis among the
initiatives is a commitment to continue
it to asset purchasing program in the
amounts needed to support smooth market
functioning and effective transmission
of monetary policy to broader financial
conditions in the
me that's a long way of saying the
Federal Reserve is gonna pump and pump
and pump and pump and buy and buy and
buy and buy there's only one problem
with that where does that money come
from either you got to inflate it or you
got to sell bonds the bond yields are
going up which means demand is going
down nobody trusts that this money is
ever going to get repaid it's why the
Trump administration floated last week
25 to 50 year bonds okay the bottom line
is at a certain point the restrictions
are gonna have to come off industries
why I say we got to keep assessing this
on a moment-by-moment basis as more data
comes in and we should because if indeed
this results in the catastrophic
destruction of American business then we
got a problem and the job of the federal
government right now in terms of
compensating these businesses is
basically provides zero interest loans
to all of the companies that are that
are hurting right now to pay back
overtime or grants to to these companies
to pay back or not pay back overtime
because most of these will end up being
forgiven float the companies the cash
right now and yes float the companies
the cash and this turns out to be the
major sticking point with the Democrats
so over the weekend it appeared that the
Republican bill that was being pushed by
Mitch McConnell which had some fairly
significant flaws in it but was
certainly better than nothing right that
Republican it was an emergency measure
it had to be pushed now that over the
weekend that Republican bill appeared to
have gone bipartisan and people
basically approved of it in fact Senate
Minority Leader Chuck Schumer he said on
Saturday night there's been a lot of
bipartisan cooperation yes it was
pledged by the Republicans but it seems
like we're all coming together around
this thing you think it'll be wrapped up
by Monday well I hope it is we're having
good bipartisan agreements the initial
bill leader McConnell put in didn't have
any Democratic input and we were worried
they would just try to put it on the
floor and not consult Speaker Pelosi
because the house still has to pass this
but actually to my delight and surprise
there has been a great deal of
bipartisan cooperation thus far okay and
it looked as though this thing was gonna
get done like yesterday and then Nancy
Pelosi walked through the door threw a
bomb on the table and said no we're not
gonna do any of this we're going back to
the drawing board we're not doing any of
this she said we'll introduce our own
bill hopefully it'll be compatible with
what they discussed on the Senate side
and then she said I know that Monday
we're still talking that's on the Senate
side now that's their deadline for a
vote so she's now holding this thing up
she is she's holding it up and why is
she holding it up because what are the
major differences in the policy what is
the big sticking point the Democrats a
thing
that the Republican bill is too
pro-business their proposal I'm not
kidding you
their proposal is basically unending
unemployment insurance like for four to
six months and paid sick leave that's
their proposal okay there's only one
problem with that number one how do you
propose to pay for that when the economy
doesn't restart and two even if the
economy does restart what happens when
all of those jobs are gone now these
people are direct employees of the
federal government because the fact is
what you really need is when the clamps
come off all these businesses to go back
to work and continue paying their
employees you think people are gonna
like what do you think people are going
to have the ability to do with
unemployment money that goes four to six
months eventually this will morph into
universal basic income but in a very
high level right now that $1,000 a month
like Andrew Yang says but at several
thousand dollars a month you'll get
Ward's of the state
in fact you saw Tim Ryan the former very
very former presidential candidate in
the Democratic Party from Ohio he said
he want to bring Andrew yang and talk
about permanent ubi
okay that's a political priority that is
not a financial priority at this point
okay again there are holes in this bill
in the in the Republican bill and the
Heritage Foundation is criticized the
bill they say it provides over two
hundred billion dollars in special
assistance to specific industries in a
way that will likely encourage political
abuse what really should happen here is
that private banks should be giving out
the loans and then the Fed should be and
then the federal government should be
backing those loans giving zero interest
loans to the bank to pass out loans to
these companies that the banks can do
their own actuarial investigations and
decide what is a good loan and what is
not a good loan right that would be the
way to do this but instead the federal
government wants to micromanage the
process or the Democrats do what the
Democrats want to do is they only want
to give loans to companies that vow to
keep a certain number of their people
employed for a certain amount of time
which of course doesn't look to the
future when those industries are gonna
change but more importantly what they
really want to do is not give very much
assistance to business at all instead
what they want to do is go direct to
consumer so Chuck Schumer laid this out
over the weekend the Democratic plan
we're gonna go through the Democratic
plan right here and he can explain it
basically Chuck Schumer says that there
are five basic points here the Miami no
plan I'm just gonna read it to you so
Chuck Schumer says there are five basic
things first we beefed up unemployment
insurance in a huge way that has never
been done before you can call it
unemployment on steroids or employment
insurance you lose your job because of
this crisis or any other reason any
the reason the federal government will
pay you your full salary for four to six
months so we're not gonna compensate
business to pay you to do work we were
going to compensate you directly for not
doing work that is the way so what
happens to the businesses well
presumably they go bankrupt and then
they don't exist to continue paying you
right second that massive amount of
money for health care everybody's on
board with that that was in the
Republican bill in the first place and
then he says any money that goes to big
industries has to go to workers we're
going to man of the airlines you can't
lay off a single worker
you can't cut the benefits you can't cut
the salary you can't cut any of this for
any worker
at all okay well what about the fact
that when businesses come out the other
side like are there restrictions on that
so you're bailing out thing like is that
forever how exactly is that going to
work if you're an airline company and
you're gonna be destroyed for the next
two years because you are I mean people
are just not gonna fly in the way that
they were flying before for two years
now you can't lay off anybody like you
so you want it both ways you want full
unemployment four to six months and if
you're gonna give a loan then everybody
has to be kept employed forever
businesses cannot make solid business
decisions on the basis of the
possibility of a future environment you
can't furlough anybody you just have to
keep it in current cost
okay the reality is if you're trying to
shore up your company so that it is
still working at a certain point you're
going to need to actually have some
flexibility and how you run your
business it'll get some more of the
democratic plans and how this whole
thing fell apart yesterday we'll do that
in just one second first if you haven't
had a chance to see some of our contents
called all-access live you should head
over to Daley wire comm and check it out
Jeremy boring and I kicked it off late
last week actually early last week all
of the other hosted live streams over at
Daily wire calm will continue all this
week at 8 p.m. Eastern 5:00 p.m. Pacific
all exits live it's a lot more relaxed
than our normal programming it's less
focused on bringing you news and
information more about just hanging out
with you because listen we're all
together alone so I may as well just
hang out together I'm planning on being
there this afternoon a bit of a family
issue on Fridays who couldn't do it on
Friday but thank God everything is ok 5
p.m. today I should be here hanging out
with you 5 p.m. Pacific tonight join us
on all access live over at Daley
wire.com we remain the largest
fastest-growing conservative podcast and
radio show in the nation
[Music]
you
okay so as I say the truck Schumer plan
basically involves unending amounts of
money to people who are unemployed which
really again it should last as long as
the lockdown when the lockdown ends
everybody needs to go back to work
incentivizing people not to go back to
work would be the problem and if you
think that those programs are not gonna
be permanent you're wrong four to six
months of unemployment insurance is
gonna Democrats are not gonna stick to
four to six months of unemployment
insurance cuz the fallout from this
thing is gonna be broader than that
and instead of incentivizing people to
get back in the work force they're going
to incentivize people not to be back in
the work force it's one thing to
compensate people for the forest'
government shutdown it is another thing
to pay people beyond the forced
government shutdown to stay out of work
they say that they want not only paid
sick leave but paid family leave for
months at a time that they want to
forgive student loans like what in the
hell does any of this have to do with
actually shoring up the economy at this
point the Democrats apparently have
significant reservations about helping
American business this thing is just too
pro-business for them that's the big
problem Mitch McConnell last night he
slammed Nancy Pelosi for holding up the
show the Senate majority leader said we
had a deal here and then Nancy Pelosi
decided to walk it back for political
reasons here's McConnell we had a high
level of bipartisanship and five
different working groups over the last
48 hours where members who were
participating were reaching agreement
and then all of a sudden the Democratic
Leader and the Speaker of the House
shows up and we're back to square one so
we're fiddling here fiddling with the
emotions of the American people fiddling
with the markets fiddling with our
health care the American people expect
us to act tomorrow hey well that that is
all true and that's why the markets
tanked at the open they were down again
significantly at the open down like
18,000 so the market is down about 40
percent from its from its highs of just
about a month ago which is totally
insane never seen anything like it
before meanwhile again what exactly were
the Democratic objections here their big
objection the one that they are talking
about suppose
is that the there's a big slush fund
that is going to be handed out to states
and localities and businesses run by the
Treasury secretary and they're talking
point is that Trump is gonna bail out
his own businesses okay a couple of
quick things about that one if he does
like exclusively bail out his own
businesses he's not gonna win reelection
I mean that is perfectly obvious right
if the President does do that if you
were like giving a disproportionate
share of the bailout money to his own
businesses not only is he not gonna win
reelection he'd probably inviolate be in
violation of the emoluments clause to
Trump's business is very large it has
many many employees is it the idea that
because Trump's name is on the
organization all those people deserve to
be unemployed because of a vast
government shutdown so Trump shouldn't
get the same sort of consideration Trump
hotels shouldn't get the same sort of
consideration as Marriott hotels by the
way Marriott just furloughed something
like 2/3 of its employees the Fertile
includes 2/3 of its 4,000 employees at
their headquarters and 2/3 of their
174,000 employees around the world and
Democrats are holding this thing up now
if you ever want to see something
incredible about media bias the evolving
New York Times headline on this thing is
just unbelievable so the New York Times
had several headlines on this thing it
started off with a with an accurate
headline and then quickly moved to a non
accurate headline it's a Democrats block
action on 1.8 trillion dollar stimulus
within a few minutes they had changed
the headline his Sunday evening they
changed the headline to Democrats block
action on stimulus plan seeking worker
protections so now the headline is
justifying all of this because otherwise
the workers would not be protected and
then there's a third headline and then
it said partisan divide threatens deal
on rescue bill so now it wasn't even
Democrats blocking it it was just that
people couldn't come to an agreement you
see how the New York Times just I mean
that is the evolution of journalism in
real time pretty amazing so again what
exactly were they upset about according
to the New York Times which of course is
not biased in any way at all Democrats
risked a political backlash if they're
seen as obstructing progress they argued
the vote on Sunday was premature giving
the remaining reservations about the
measures negotiations continued
McConnell wanted to hold another vote at
9:45 a.m. on Monday morning 15 minutes
after markets open to demonstrate to
Democrats that their votes actually
mattered to the markets Democrats
instead pushed it back to noon at the
earliest
on Monday the
on Capitol Hill was grim because Dow
futures fell immediately upon news that
this thing started to fall apart
Democrats denounced the package is a
corporate giveaway that favored big
business over workers and failed to
ensure that bailed out companies would
not enrich themselves after receiving
government aid so they're gonna
micromanage these companies that they
have now shut down right they were
particularly incensed that the inclusion
of a provision that would give the
Federal Reserve access to 425 billion
dollars that could be leveraged for
loans to broad groups of flailing
companies we've in Congress with little
or no say in which businesses could
receive assistance or how it could be
used then one now micromanage all these
businesses they're looking to leverage
their way into businesses that were
profitable until five minutes ago when
the government forcibly shut down all
these businesses all across the country
and they're saying the business heads
don't know how to run their businesses
anymore we know how to run their
businesses anymore so instead of just
floating loans to these companies along
the basis of how they run and by the way
if you think that like ok I run a
business if you think that if we got a
loan from the government right now we
wouldn't use that to keep our people
employed that instead we would just sort
of pocket to cash for no apparent reason
you don't understand how businesses work
you really don't because in order for us
to be operational on the other side of
this we have to maintain as much of our
core employee base as humanly possible
employers are constantly deciding who to
hire and who to fire on the basis of
efficiencies okay and the fact is that
when we come out the other side of this
people are gonna need those employers
there will be a hiring boom on the other
side of this when the market recovers
but saying to companies that you're
gonna micromanage them and you're gonna
dictate that they continue to have a
certain number of employees for example
like who the hell is Chuck Schumer to
tell a company exactly how many
employees they should be paying to stay
there there should be unemployment
insurance that should be extended for
people who are laid off but also the
companies need to continue to exist
because if they don't continue to exist
these are not mutually exclusive if the
companies don't continue to exist none
of this is gonna matter and by the way
five seconds after this thing ends the
companies are going to have to fire a
bunch of people because guess what
let's say that the federal government
floats you alone and says you have to
keep 80 percent of your workforce
employed where you got a kit or you got
to keep a hundred percent of your
workforce employed or we are not going
to give you the money what do you think
happens on the other side of this when
we come out of lockdown and the market
is still not there because gonna take a
little while for the market to recover
all those people are didn't get it laid
off anyway so what exactly are you
talking about
the business is gonna take a major hit
businesses know how best to run their
businesses and yes we should be tithing
people over yes we should be ensuring
that they are furloughed rather than
fired yes we should be ensuring that
those small businesses continue to exist
but the the I don't love the Republican
bill but I like the Democratic proposals
even less unending employment
unemployment insurance no loans to go
basically cut down all the loans so that
Chuck Schumer can decide which
businesses ought to get the loans and
they can control exactly how these
businesses run pretty pretty wild stuff
and it does smack of a political agenda
and if that becomes permanent if
Democrats think that they get to run the
run all of these business from the top
down because the government declared
that they were going to shut down all
these businesses in the first place it's
the greatest seizure of private property
in the history of the United States if
that's the case if what you have here I
mean other than slavery obviously then I
don't mean the end of slavery I mean the
seizure of private property meaning like
you own your own labor if somebody
enslaves you then obviously that's a
seizure of you and your property okay
but other than the evil enslavement of
human beings this is the greatest
destruction of private property in the
history of the United States if you are
talking about shutting down vast swathes
of companies and then saying to them
that in return for the loan we now get
to run your company basically forever
without an end point because the
Democrats are not proposing any end
point here Democrats say they're
concerned about how the government would
go about bailing out to stress companies
complaining the measure would give too
much discretion to minuchin to decide
who received funds would allow too much
time before he'd have to disclose the
recipients because the measure gives the
Treasury secretary six months to reveal
all of this stuff the draft bill would
provide a total of five hundred billion
dollars in loans and other support for
distressed cities states and industries
including 50 billion for passenger
Airlines eight billion dollars for cargo
carriers again I don't love any of this
but it's not exactly a bailout when you
are forcing these things to shut down in
the first place under the Republicans
draft bill the federal government would
be allowed to take stock shares or other
equity in any business that accepts
loans under the program that's a
provision the administration had floated
publicly I don't even like that
provision but with that said shutting
this thing down over democratic
priorities at this point is pretty
astonishing at the last minute okay time
for a quick thing that I like and then a
quick thing that I hate so things that I
like today so I've been sitting home
with the kids and that means that it's
time to catch up on the movies because
let me just tell you when you of a six
year
you have a three-year-old you can do as
much homeschooling as possible and then
everybody needs a break so there's a fun
movie that didn't get tons of attention
when it came out but it is kind of a
kick called spies in disguise with Will
Smith and Tom Holland the basic premise
of the film is incredibly silly and also
funny which is a Will Smith is a secret
agent Tom Holland is sort of the cue
character except that the cute character
only makes very very odd devices that
are sort of directed at non-violence and
it's in about 30 minutes into the film
the cue character in order to allow Will
Smith to hide from the authorities
transforms Will Smith into a pigeon and
so he's a pigeon for like half the film
and the movies actually quite funny and
and quite and quite charming spies in
disguise there's a little bit the
trailer imagine if I can make you
disappear hey Lance look at me look at
you I can see my butt and your face at
the same time that is so cool being a
pigeon could make you an even better spy
ginger everywhere nobody notices them
and I just can see in slow motion
hi did anyone else see a pigeon okay so
the movies actually pretty funny and and
if it's a good kids movie it's worthy of
checking out a little bit scary for for
like the very very young crowd but if
they're over like seven maybe over six I
watched with my six and three year old
so I'm in responsible but let's be real
we're all in quarantine so it's a my
daughter loved it she thought it was
hilarious she's a little mature for her
age in terms of what she watches however
okay time for a quick thing that I hate
alrighty so celebrities are really bored
and I think that what this quarantine
has shown more than anything else with
it but this whole lockdown has shown
more than anything else is that
celebrities desire attention more than
anything in the world right this is why
they're releasing videos of themselves
singing imagine and why they're on
Instagram talking about how life is
really difficult at their palatial
estates and everything like listen
celebrities we don't care here's the
thing about celebrities that many of
them don't really understand we don't
care that much about you when you are
not reading a line and when you're not
reading a line you're just not all that
interesting what makes you interesting
as the lines you're reading you're good
at acting right off off screen when I'm
not doing politics I got to say my life
is fairly boring okay I think that most
celebrities don't understand this and so
they think they have very important
things to say even when they're doing
bizarre things so um Madonna in a video
that you cannot unsee did a video
yesterday from her bathtub about how
coronavirus is the greatest equalizer in
the world she said from her bathtub that
has rose petals in it just like
everybody else who's like normal right
like I know that that when I give my
child the bath I have rose petals in
there because like that's the way I run
here is here is Madonna explaining to
all of us about the Equality of
coronavirus from her presumably
multimillion-dollar estates in a bathtub
filled with rose petals like any normal
human being
it doesn't care about how rich you are
how famous you are how funny you are
how smart you are where you live how old
you are
or the amazing stories we can tell it's
the great equalizer um and then they pan
over there's just some random dude
playing the piano in her bathroom while
she's naked in her bathtub filled with
rose petals
okay celebrities they need our attention
don't give it to them I just defeated my
own rule giving attention to Madonna who
is so desperate for attention also yes
that's true of cover 19 it's also just
called death like death generally tends
to be a pretty great equalizer um yeah
yeah so I think that maybe it's time to
dump our celebrity culture is that fair
can we can we be done with this already
all right we'll be back here later day
two additional hours of content plus 5
p.m. today I'm gonna show up we're gonna
hang out together I know I'm gonna take
time out of my very non busy schedule
other than dealing with my screaming
children to come hang out with you so
join up over a daily where all of our
members get access it's not just an
all-access thing right now because we
all want to hang out together showing up
over a daily wire calm otherwise we'll
see you here later or tomorrow I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the bench Bureau show
the Benton Shapiro show is produced by
Colton Haas
directed by Mike joiner executive
producer Jeremy boring supervising
producer Mathis Glover and Robert
Stirling assistant director pavel white
house key technical producer austin
stevens playback and media operated by
nick Sheehan associate producer Katie
Swinton edited by Adam sy events audio
is mixed by Mike foramina hair and
makeup is by Anika Geneva the Ben
Shapiro show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 20 nearly
700,000 people filed for unemployment
last week more unemployment claims than
we saw at the peak of the 2009 recession
we will examine the promising signs for
a cure to corona virus and perhaps more
importantly the promising signs that
President Trump is ready to free us from
the dictatorship of public health
experts then mainstream media
journalists humiliate themselves because
today is a day ending and why and new
york city government publishes a helpful
guide on how to have sanitary group
sodomy during the pandemic all that and
more check it out on the Michael Noel's
show
you
[Music]